The implementation is recursive in nature and perhaps the easiest way
to describe it in simple terms is to give an example that
can easily be generalized.
Here's how we can do it
when N is equal to 32.
So there are five qubits.
To be clear, we're associating the
standard basis states of these five qubits with the integers between zero and 31 using binary notation.
The first thing we do is to perform the quantum Fourier
transform for N equals 16 to all of the qubits except for
the least significant Qubit,
which is the one on the top. And that's the recursive
part of the construction.
So to implement this operation, we have to follow the same
pattern but with one fewer Qubit.
And in the base case we
have just a single Qubit for which the quantum Fourier transform is just a Hadamard gate.
Once we apply the QFT on all of the qubits except for the top one, we apply a bunch of controlled phase gates using the phases that are
indicated in the diagram.
We then apply a Hadamard
gate to the top Qubit, and shuffle the qubits around a little bit using some swap gates.
These swap gates have the effect of cyclically permuting the qubits which is needed to make
the construction work.
We can follow exactly the same pattern for other choices of N
provided they're powers of two, where we always start the
controlled phase gates
with alpha being pi over
two for the bottom Qubit and dividing by two each time
moving left in the diagram
to get the subsequent phases. Now it's not at all obvious
that this construction works.
And I'm not gonna explain
why it works in this video.
If you're interested in seeing
the details for why it works, you can find them in the
written content for the lesson.
I will say however that
what's being exploited here is the basic structure of
discrete Fourier transforms
and in fact it's exactly
the same structure that allows the fast
Fourier transform to work.
Another way to say this is that if we look at the fast Fourier transform, we can think about it in
terms of quantum circuits.
And this is the circuit that we get.
So how many gates do we need in total for this implementation?
To figure that out, let's let SM be the number of gates that
we need when we have M qubits.
When M is equal to one, we just need a single gate because the QFT is just a Hadamard operation in this case.
If M is at least two, then these
are the gates that we need.
First we need SM minus one gates for the quantum Fourier
transform on M minus one qubits, whatever that number happens to be.
We also need M minus one
controlled phase gates, M minus one swap gates,
and one additional Hadamard gate.
So here's an expression
of SM in both cases when M is equal to one and
when M is at least two.
This is an example of what's called a recurrence relation and
they show up very commonly in the analysis of algorithms.
This particular one
happens to be very simple and it has a so-called
closed form expression, which we can obtain by summing.
To be precise, the value of SM is the sum of the first M
consecutive odd integers, which equals M squared,
as you may have either encountered before or maybe you just noticed that
at some point in your life.
And it happens to be pretty easy to prove this formula is true by induction on M in
case you're interested in a formal proof.
So that's it. We can implement the
quantum Fourier transform on M qubits using M squared gates.
Just a couple of very
quick additional remarks.
First we don't actually
need all of the swap gates that I've described.
It is possible to effectively
push them all out to the end as long as we adjust which qubits the controlled phase gates
act on appropriately.
And if we do that we'll only
need M over two swap gates in total rounding down.
We'll still have a quadratic cost, but the number of gates can be reduced in this way nevertheless.
And one final remark is that we can actually make the cost even less if we're willing to settle for
a pretty good approximation.
For example, when M gets large, a lot of the controlled phase gates are pretty close to
the identity operation,
and eliminating the
ones that are very close can save us quite a lot on gates while still giving us a
pretty good approximation.
It is also possible to approximate the quantum Fourier transform
with very shallow circuits, meaning ones with small depth, in case that's something
that we wish to do.
And now that we know what the
quantum Fourier transform is for different dimensions, as well as how it can be implemented w hen the dimension is a power of two,
we can go back to the
phase estimation procedure and see how it can be generalized where we use some arbitrary
number M of control qubits.
Here's what the procedure looks like as a quantum circuit for
an arbitrary choice of M.
We have M control qubits on top, which we assume are all
initialized to the zero state.
We apply a Hadamard
gate to each one of them and then each of them is
used as a control Qubit to apply some power of
the unitary operation U,